[Music]
yo no [ __ ] given news homie I don't
give the [ __ ] today submitted by Justin
from Chicago
sha sha shitty man an officer will allow
two suspects to make it out in the back
of his patrol car is now suspended to
make out make out [ __ ] funny wait I
didn't make it out oh my bad dude I'm
Trey were in love hee hee she's so he
made out with the did a girl or good
dude
so this is a mine an officer who allowed
two suspects oh he got in the back of
his patrol car is now suspended Oh bro I
wish I could see like who as we're
reading this or as you guys read it like
we can see what everyone is thinking as
they hear the word thought to quit
members I'm gonna go away homie I see
all of this and then he saw the cop and
then a girl no cuz cuz I was in a
similar situation where I got arrested
and the cop put me in a car and there
was a girl in a civilian clothes right I
was just kind of like thinking like what
the [ __ ] why is somebody in no in the
front seat and I was like um sorry you
guys like friends or something and she
was like uh I guess you could say that
damned and you were in the backseat I
was in the backseat handcuffed you know
I was like have been from ride-along or
something she's getting her dick suck
I'm going to show you what I do well I
uh what's wrong with two suspects make
you know if they're both belong back
there well because it goes against their
policies in jail it's a lot of things
they didn't have their seat belts on the
guy was handcuffed in the front the girl
wasn't even handcuffed
oh so she was finger banging her dude
well I don't know that is not wrong they
were doing sexual activity back there
cos were in the front that means he
could just why do you know so she was
doing video drugs probably
um so this
because of like a shoplifting thing and
so you picked them up and then she even
let them smoke in the backseat what the
facilitator of love yeah they were
saying that there was there was very
white can't get enough of your level I
know exactly what happened to he's going
through a divorce right now with his
wife and he saw a young love and he goes
you know what guys you guys love each
other so you go for it this is your
chance go ahead you're some very white
video the visible that's his his body
camera on but like hanging on those
that's amazing you wanted to see them
[ __ ] so he could get the footage for
later okay drinking Mountain Dew yeah
here's Jim and transported without
handcuffs oh the man to see you yeah
he's recording it for sure that you are
captured cuddling kissing and eventually
performing sex acts on each other while
the officer please sucking dick or
finger banging the [ __ ] out of each
other
the Sallyport of the jail
you really not but it's fine other
officer has even expressed to McNeil the
obvious contact happening in the back
then he transports them to the hospital
for an injury to the man's leg again
he's unrestrained what is going on what
do they give that guy's just a really
chill [ __ ] did he just like you have a
cop just being a brewery's a perfect
yeah why is he recording them that makes
them perv all I know is [ __ ] dude I
wish I will get arrested by this guy
that means they never they don't have
violent criminals raised from yeah cuz
he was he wasn't scared when someone
pulled out a lighter behind him yeah
yeah you're in a vulnerable position
what part of Florida though because
element Melbourne Melbourne Florida cuz
if it spells me to Florida it's quite
nice there damn that's crazy
for Fort Pierce they mentioned two
different places I don't know which one
is Oh Miami by the way is a fantastic
place because there's a bunch of chicks
with nice bodies excuse me the correct
term is big booty [ __ ] was it hot
when you it was 80 degrees and [ __ ]
beautiful did in February the beach is
beautiful
or the big booty hoes [ __ ] who are so
beautiful they are they all wearing
g-strings I will say this right now it's
almost a crime if you don't look the Jew
because you're just wasting it huh no
it's not wasting it's like clearly
they're there because they're trying to
get some attention there's not a line of
guys going there's like there's like
these two girls today next to me and ten
just [ __ ] shaking their ass like
twerking yeah and it's February I'm like
what do you do what is this it's not
even talking season
[Laughter]
I was like am I supposed to look at my
not supposed to look I thought it was
like a trick I just took it as in like
the weather I know I know but it's just
me the way Talitha was working season as
February is not working season I would
say it's from June to August and all the
dudes there are [ __ ] likes roided-out
pink skin and everything [ __ ] blood
pressure yeah man so if you're Miami to
do at night when you're walking by all
these restaurants they are trying to get
you to sit down in that [ __ ] table
aggressively so what are you going today
free shots of tequila come here come
here and then we'll like grab you and
[ __ ] and I denied everybody until this
one big titted Cuban lady grabbed me and
all she had to do was she goes you want
fries I was like I heard this [ __ ]
before dude she was no come on well I
had to go you're like I saw he was booby
trapped booby trap really bad but the
real reason why that's jew Tetsu I was
but the reason why I really went there
is because they were playing nice soft
music I wasn't that loud young [ __ ] off
it was her tit yes tits yeah and we got
a free shot of really terrible tequila
when you called it lady wasn't as
attractive as she was a little mean the
way she said it
this one was also very mean but she had
nice titties
that makes them nicer and I'm not even
like the food at one of the restaurants
we went there it was so bad oh I have
some good food there what did you eat
kuben food so at the airport I got like
Cuban food which was fantastic it was
just as good as Porto's cuz there you
have a bunch of cute me people in Miami
anyways so there's really matter but
yeah we just had like like chicken wings
or whatever all that drunk people food
it was pretty [ __ ] good chunk yes
oh that's why were there Asians there
there was there was some baddie asian
girls there
and I thought they were disgusting
Muriel French yeah you're so gross
I only want to look at girls I don't
want to get to know them you don't got
to get to know him he's got a look on I
just look it's so weird a such a cuz
Miami is that South East Miami is such a
tourist place like nobody is really from
there you know I mean they're there
because they see the South Beach Miami
life and I trying to emulate it as hard
as possible most of the people there are
locals
they're just tourists not in the South
Beach area that's specifically a tourist
area so people are there to have fun
tan and do all the other [ __ ] all the
locals probably live like a few blocks
the other way I just picture uh-oh D and
then grandmas with the t shirts that
have the bikini girl draw we're like
South Beach is like where that Muscle
Beach [ __ ] is so you see people doing
pull-ups ah but things like popping over
there man so if you drink and you like
very intelligent women it's like it's
like that scene in Scarface when they're
at South Beach yeah get at the woman the
guys that look at those deities Mike I
was doing I would not know cuz I don't
attend those things you sick bastard to
have good conversations there too as
they're stripping on you it is I would
like a conversation club a lot of them
bore the [ __ ] out of me man what is that
like a conversation like a hostess club
I guess oh oh I see I see where the
girls talk like a dope ass talk like
diam do that's [ __ ] dope you talk
I'll have your girlfriend
I guess the novelty is different when
it's like someone different no stranger
that guys stranger news stories nuisance
yeah a different person so it's not even
romantic it's like well I guess like
that's some gay [ __ ] right because they
have education [ __ ] yeah and in the the
hooker in the in the in the Greek times
or the Roman times all there all of
those hookers they were like supposedly
really good at conversation like they
could talk you're so funny you're like
yeah I just wish that really pale faces
and black teeth and and they could play
the [ __ ] 2 string violin and [ __ ]
they could do performances affecting the
[ __ ] peekaboo show behind the door
[ __ ] hell I don't know how that [ __ ]
was fun I'll watch that [ __ ] now I'm
like that's just hidden that TV is [ __ ]
back in there not Instagram back yeah
they didn't have like as distractions
those were film they have these like
performances right these purists are
trying to keep it and it's like a dying
art cuz know young people want to watch
it right and it's like oh yeah and they
seem like that and they [ __ ] step
like two steps and then they go a
different way they step two steps I'm
like this is boring as [ __ ] dude this
shit's [ __ ] wack my ancient people it
sounds like that it's not even Japanese
well it might be but it's like ancient
Japanese that's it literally sound like
that I'm like what the [ __ ] is this yeah
they say music [ __ ] this [ __ ] I rather
listen to the Japanese I'm who's man
they're [ __ ] there's a native tribe
out there they [ __ ] play that biiian
biiian anywhere you go you look for that
hill behind
playing biting
[Music]